So far, our units have focused on showing that problems are hard
or NP complete to be more precise.
Actually, what I have very often observed in practice,
and even in scientific papers where the office did not have a
solid background in theoretical computer sciences is this.
Once a problem is shown to be NP complete,
many people would  just tend to give up or come up with some,
well honestly terrible algorithm that they've justified with.
Well, the problem was NP complete,
and that is why we're now going to turn our attention
to count the measures against NP completeness.
So, this unit and the following units are your first aid kit to help you overcome NP completeness
or at least take a bit of the sting out of it
because imagine you find yourself in the situation like the four computer scientist
that we have gotten to know throughout this course like Alice, Bob, Carol, and Dave.
Solving tough problems was part of their job.
Alice was solving vertex cover for telecommunications;
Bob was working in biotech developing new medicines, analyzing genes;
Carol was working in finance designing secure investments;
and Dave was working in logistics where he had to solve the shortest tool problem
and actually there are logistics companies who developed algorithms
with which they save millions everyday and also fuel.
So, those problems are practically relevant although they are NP complete.
So, when your company or your boss asked you to solve an NP complete problem,
what should you do--should you say, "I want another problem,"
should you make her or him take this course so that they finally understand NP completeness,
should you say "It's impossible to do that,"
should you say "It's proven impossible,"
or should you say "It's proven difficult but we can try."